do you ever get a request that betrays
an insane kink like a kink that i know
you're you're non-judgmental which you
should be but does anyone ever say i
want something and you just no i can't
accommodate this or i've never heard of
this before there's never been one that
i won't do there have been so many that
i haven't heard of um one guy who has
bought several times from me him and his
wife are belly button fetishists and
first of all i'm so glad they found each
other right like
yes i was thinking that same thing they
both are did they know that before they
got married you know what as they as
people it's for every mickey there's a
mini you know uh for every audi there's
an innie it says yes
yes that's the quip of the week that's a
good one uh
i've made both of them harnesses
harnesses that have like big o rings
that like cinch their waist and like
push into their belly buttons
um and i had to actually reach out to a
welder i know to have some custom metal
pieces made because for one of them they
wanted like a piece of pipe that was
going to sort of push into their belly
button and it was funny because at one
point the welder was like do i need to
like smooth out the inside of the pipe
like are they going to be [ __ ] the
pipe so then i had to email the customer
and be like is the pipe they're pushing
into the belly button are we going to be
putting any sensitive body parts into
the pipe and he was like no of course
not and i was like i don't know i love
you know what i i love that i love that
you're just talking to a friend of yours
who's a welder he's like yeah
emma what are you what can i help you
with uh so hey uh are they gonna be
[ __ ] the pipe
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah okay better galvanize it all right
so they're gonna be [ __ ] the pipes so
i won't go i'm not gonna go copper if
they're gonna be [ __ ] the pipe uh all
right let me ask one more question hey
uh another quick question i got for you
gonna be sticking this in the ass at all
oh they are okay so all right bruce
bruce we're doing a [ __ ] pipe bruce
bruce bruce bruce we need another [ __ ]
pipe
well just i know i know that's six this
week but just add a seventh we got it we
can get it done
uh man i love i love the mundane
technical questions uh wow this is
fascinating this is just fascinating and
um so emma i'm told that uh you have
gotten involved more recently uh in the
um
the furry sensation is that right that
were people wearing furry costumes that
do you attend conventions where people
dress up in furry costumes yeah i
attended my first one a couple months
ago it's called midwest furfest um and
for a lot of the furries which you know
are people who who have their fursuits
and their fursonas and it's this other
character that they become and they're
you know giant mascot costumes that hide
that hide every inch of them uh and
and there's a big community for it and
and there is some of some of them there
is a sexual element to it for a lot of
them it's not sexual at all it's just uh
it's just playing but i did i did uh
i've ended there and uh
yeah we're showing you right now some
photos of a horse an opossum that are
wearing uh leather harnesses
and these photos will be available on
team coco podcasts on instagram just if
you want to check those out because
you're going to want to see these okay
so
i see so you don't make the leather you
don't make the fur costumes you make
leather harnesses for people dressed up
in fur costumes
i mean mostly for people i'd say a lot
of the people at furfest who bought from
me it was like 60 of them bought
harnesses to wear outside of their
fursuits because there's a big you know
there's a big overlap between people who
are furries and people who are kinksters
and sometimes sometimes they are not
kinky as their fursona it's just a
separate thing so a lot of people bought
harnesses just to wear over their normal
mortal bodies but then some people
bought harnesses to wear uh to wear when
they're in their fursona oh i see what
you kept saying first sona i was
thinking of sona you mean instead of
persona it's fur sona it's yeah yeah i
thought people dressed up as a like a
furry version of sona
there was a lot of that there yeah
i bet you there is gonna you know sona
has quite a following and i bet you
someone's gonna someone's gonna go as a
fur sona uh and uh that's that's gonna
become a sensation and be a huge honor
yeah so this is uh and you say some of
it is sexual but you never know so you
could be talking to someone in a furry
costume and not know if this is a kink
or if this is just them playing around
and having fun but there's nothing
sexual attached right yeah okay before
we wrap up i think there's a really
important question that emma has that i
want to get to to make sure we hear this
question do you know what i'm talking
about yeah yeah well i was thinking uh i
i name all of my harnesses and sometimes
i just sort of pull names out of thin
air because i'm uh running out of ideas
but frequently i named them after people
uh you know different characters or uh
sometimes the first person who modeled
that harness but i was i want to name a
harness uh the catechi harness
the cat
that's good yeah and i was wondering
after kind of what kind of harness uh
yeah would the catechi harness is that a
name befitting of like a strap-on
harness or like a bustier type of
harness
uh well that was a story of goodness
with that people sorry that's my
alarm going off but that can wait
[Laughter]
uh no it can't actually you might want
to get on that
anything you want to tell us or
everything's good
everything's great okay all right my
birth is under control uh
okay
okay uh
wow all right well the catechism
harness
okay the catechi refers to uh uh james
lipton of course the esteemed uh uh
uh dean of the actor's studio uh was uh
i told a story once on the show that has
just reverberated and it was about uh
his wife katakai and he says the line in
the story catechi as god made her so um
i have a lot of respect uh for the late
james lipton and of course uh and by
extension uh for his lovely wife catechi
so i think there should be respect here
i think it should be made of the finest
materials i know that uh i know that uh
dean lipton was very open-minded uh and
had lived a rich and full life so
um he would be thrilled i'm sure he'd be
thrilled there was
a strap-on or a harness made uh in in in
his honor the catechi so um i i just
think it my only insistence is that be
made of the finest materials the very
same thing sort of a higher ticket item
i think it has to be the highest ticket
all right i think the catechi has to be
you're not using brass you're using gold
the leather
uh has to be uh found human leather
human leather
i don't think our skin is actually thick
enough to make a functional bondage
fairness not that i've put a lot of
thought into it mine is after being on
this bucket
[Music]
i've toughened him up real nice
he's ready to be turned into a skin suit
yes the catechi is made of gourley
leather
gold fittings
um
get your get
make sure it has a good [ __ ] cage on it
and make sure you get that that welder
on the phone to get the very finest
materials get lou on the line and make
sure that this is [ __ ] pipe
jesus this is terrible what what an
awful conversation and yet at the same
time also quite beautiful one last thing
before we go uh last night i uh you know
i don't know what happened last night
well i made something for you conan oh
look at that
is that like a butt harness no it's it's
a bulldog harness but i you know i would
make you a butt harness if you ask
nicely what's a bulldog harness it's
green it's st patrick's day green i
figured you'd look like a submissive
little leprechaun in it um which is all
anyone's ever wanted
so it goes oh my god it goes over your
chest like this oh that's gorgeous yeah
i love that
because i love you just connect a leash
to or something you can yeah
oh you know what it is
this is my fetish uh i would wear that
okay and i'd be uh
restrained and i'd be saying to my
mistress i want me pot of gold and she'd
be saying you can't have your pot of
gold and i'd say i want a pot of gold
it should say no pot of gold for you and
i will say a hearty pot of gold you get
the pot of gold when i say you get the
pot of gold and no sooner and oh exactly
i love i love the submissive leprechaun
that's gonna be
my new character um
the submissiveness
sure it will i'll probably
i'll wear it every day under my shirt
and uh my fans will know i'm wearing it
uh i'm a delight talking to you and um
you're clearly uh very gifted and uh
you're out there
letting people be themselves and letting
people
um let their
inner selves out and flourish it's very
nice you're doing uh you're doing good
work so
onward and upward for you emma thanks
dad
sorry i just made it weird
it was it wasn't weird before finally
weird yeah well
so
i should have said i think it's good
all right i'm going to uh i'm going to a
catholic mass right now
right don't forget your little harness
don't worry i've got the harness nothing
weird happens at catholic masses
okay emma that's it i'm done with you um
i love them emma you're the best
seriously thank you very much man all
right see y'all